la terza guerra di non perdiamo tempo la terza guerra di indipendenza io spero che non so quanti
di voi c'erano le volte scorse con chi c'era le volte scorse mi sento poi in imbarazzo perché
la storia è sempre la stessa cioè si spinge da occidente e quegli altri cercano di impedire che
si conquisti lombardo veneto o meglio no nel 1866 qualcosina è cambiato dal punto di vista
geografico sette anni prima con la seconda guerra di indipendenza la lombardia è stata presa quindi
il confine non è più al ticino il confine è al mincio però chi c'era le volte scorse si ricorda
che problemi hanno avuto gli eserciti piemontesi e francesi per attraversarlo questo benedetto
mincio i problemi ci sono quindi sempre si tratta di spingere verso oriente partendo dal mincio e
poi però c'è un'altra differenza grossa nella prima guerra di indipendenza c'era un esercito
piemontese che da solo non avrebbe mai potuto farcela a sconfiggere l'austria però l'austria
era in piena rivoluzione e gli altri sovrani italiani avevano promesso di aiutare e quindi
ci hanno provato ed è andata come è andata la seconda guerra di indipendenza invece è stata
vinta perché accanto all'esercito piemontese c'era quello francese tre volte tanto e quindi
c'era una certa superiorità numerica rispetto alle forze austriache adesso nel 66 la cosa è ancora
cambiata perché di qua dal mincio non c'è più il regno di sardegna c'è il regno d'italia il re è
sempre lo stesso e si chiama sempre vittorio emanuele secondo ha preferito non cambiare neanche
il numero ma ma il regno è il regno d'italia e si vede l'esercito rispetto all'esercito piemontese
è quadruplicato nel 59 i piemontesi avevano in campo cinque divisioni nel 66 gli italiani hanno in
campo 20 divisioni è un esercito che è come tutto il paese in una strana fase di transizione
perché da un lato si sta cercando di costruire un paese che si chiami italia e che attinga le
risorse di tutta la penisola e dall'altra però l'impronta piemontese sabauda è comunque sempre
fortissima nell'esercito questo si vede bene è un esercito che da un lato ha una predominanza
piemontese nell'elite dei generali ancora molto netta d'altra parte però è indiscutibilmente un
esercito italiano mi spiego se noi guardiamo i quattro corpi d'armata in cui è diviso l'esercito
i quattro comandanti dei corpi d'armata sono due piemontesi e quindi sono sempre sovra rappresentati
però un toscano e un modenese se guardiamo i generali di divisione delle 12 divisioni che
combattono sul mincio e che vanno incontro alla battaglia di custozza se noi guardiamo chi sono i
12 generali di queste 12 divisioni sei vengono dall'esercito piemontese di nuovo la preponderanza
è netta ma non è assoluta due vengono dall'esercito napoletano il pianel e il nunziante sono ex
generali del re di napoli passati nel regno d'italia uno viene dal granducato di toscana e poi su 12
generali di divisione ci sono ben tre garibaldini sirtori cosenz nino bixio sono generali di divisione
dell'esercito italiano con i garibaldini l'esercito non è stato in generale molto generoso c'era molta
diffidenza verso questa gente un po troppo di sinistra rispetto ai gusti dei generali sabaudi e
quindi si sono fatte molte difficoltà ai garibaldini per prendere servizio nell'esercito italiano ma ai
generali invece si sono fatti i ponti d'oro quei generali di garibaldi che hanno voluto mettere la divisa
blu l'hanno messa e quindi come vedete c'è una fusione in corso ancora squilibrata ancora incompleta
con mille difficoltà per esempio una difficoltà ci sono due generali napoletani benissimo nunziante e pianel
ma sul loro conto girano tutti i pettegolezzi possibili sono ex generali dei borboni saranno
fedeli o sono pronti a tradire girano così tanto queste voci infondate che ancora oggi non sappiamo
se sono i servizi segreti austriaci che le hanno messe in giro appositamente per seminare zizzania e i
soldati delle divisioni comandate da questi generali le sentono queste voci e le rilanciano
fra i soldati della divisione di pianela a un certo punto corre la voce che il generale si è scoperto
che voleva consegnare la divisione al nemico alla prima occasione che è stato arrestato e fucilato non
è vero niente ma tra i soldati le voci corrono con una facilità e poi c'è la difficoltà di creare un
esercito italiano mettendo insieme gente che viene da tutte le regioni e che sia per le differenze
regionali sia per l'eredità comunque degli ultimi anni di contrapposizioni e beh conserva delle
ostilità reciproche l'italia non è un paese unito neanche adesso da quel punto di vista non lo era
neanche allora gli aneddoti su come nelle caserme ci si mena fra piemontesi e napoletani fra lombardi
e siciliani pieno di questi aneddoti ve ne cito un paio dalle memorie di un bersagliere piemontese
giovanni rossetti vecchio soldato di lungo corso che ha fatto il 59 e che poi viene richiamato per il 66
il bersagliere rossetti racconta di quella volta che in caserma ha dovuto intervenire per fermare dice
due napoletani che minacciavano un piemontese e continua ce l'avevano già fatto sentire questi
maccheroni che volevano rivoltarsi a noi piemontesi e lombardi fra noi vi regnava sempre guerra continua
con questa razza diabolica e quella volta finisce non solo a botte ma a coltelli sguainati con rossetti
che in camerata grida fuori tutti i napoletani è ora di finirla con questi maccheronacci traditori
dall'altra parte il sentimento è amorevolmente ricambiato ben inteso questo che vi cito adesso
è dai volumi di sentenze dei tribunali militari di quegli anni nella caserma del 45esimo fanteria
pinerolo il soldato giuseppe maiolino napoletano aggredisce a calci e pugni il caporale viriglio
piemontese il caporale morelli napoletano interviene a difendere il collega piemontese
aggredito al che il soldato cantoriello napoletano esclama cane d'un caporale tu sei napoletano e prendi
la difesa di questi piemontesi stai bene allerta che se non potrò farti la festa questa notte te la
farò infallibilmente domani denuncia temunale militare sei mesi di galera e solite cose insomma
allora io i miei dubbi che nell'esercito austriaco boemi e ungheresi andassero d'amore d'accordo
per cui queste cose non hanno mai impedito a un esercito di funzionare però bisogna tenerle presenti
sono comunque i segni di una compagine non matura non pienamente compatta non pienamente unita e
tuttavia questo esercito va in guerra con ottime speranze perché le circostanze del 1866 non potrebbero
essere più favorevoli voi ricordate che punto siamo nel 59 si era vinto solferino si poteva andare
avanti arrivare a venezia invece napoleone terzo per tanti motivi ha deciso che andava bene così che
bastava regalare la lombardia ai savoia il veneto un'altra volta quindi questa è la prima priorità del
regno d'italia non abbiamo ancora buttato fuori gli austriaci hanno ancora il veneto hanno venezia
bisogna buttarli fuori un'altra guerra arriverà di sicuro nel 66 la guerra arriva perché non per
ragioni di politica italiana nel 66 la guerra arriva per ragioni europee perché l'austria non è solo le
grani in italia che se fosse solo quello l'austria fino a quel momento era la potenza dominante nel mondo
di lingua tedesca ma c'è un altro paese c'è un altro regno nel mondo tedesco che è in crescita da
tanto tempo e che è deciso a buttare fuori l'austria da questa posizione egemonica quest'altro paese è la
prussia che nessuno lo sa ancora ma sarà la grande potenza militare di questa seconda metà dell'ottocento
nel 1866 per vari motivi i tempi sono maturi la prussia si prepara a dichiarare guerra all'austria
e a questo punto ovviamente prussia e italia hanno interessi in comune si discute si dialoga si negozia
si ci si mette d'accordo la prussia e l'italia faranno la guerra insieme l'8 aprile del 66 viene
firmata l'alleanza tra il re di prussia e il re d'italia il 15 giugno 1866 la prussia con un
pretesto dichiara guerra all'austria ci si aspetta ovviamente che l'italia immediatamente in base
all'accordo dichiari guerra all'austria non vi stupirà sapere che gli italiani decidono di aspettare
ancora un momentino prima di vedere aspettano una settimana scarsa poi alla fine il 20 giugno si
decidono dichiariamo guerra anche noi e si concentra l'esercito sul mincio chi c'era ieri ricorda che
la guerra del 59 è stata la prima guerra moderna combattuta nella pianura padana in cui le truppe
si trasportavano in treno anche adesso nel 66 si portano in treno il concentramento dell'esercito
sul mincio è in realtà per una volta un capolavoro logistico questo esercito è sparso in mezzo a
italia bisogna concentrarlo molto rapidamente le ferrovie sono quelle che sono ma insomma
cominciano a esserci l'esercito viene concentrato rapidamente sul mincio sulla frontiera e ci sono
tutte le possibilità di vincere ed è impossibile perdere perché noi abbiamo 220 mila uomini gli
austriaci 220 mila uomini li hanno in boemia a fronteggiare l'invasione prussiana per l'italia
gliene sono rimasti 75 mila quindi noi abbiamo noi invadiamo il veneto passando il mincio con 220 mila
uomini dall'altra parte loro ne hanno 75 mila se state cominciando a chiedervi come abbiamo fatto
a perdere avete ragione il problema è quello naturalmente come abbiamo fatto a perdere allora
un problema di fondo è chi comanda questo grande esercito non tanto omogeneo e non tanto ben funzionante
chi lo comanda e beh c'è sempre il re vittorio però vittorio sono passati un po di anni ho
cominciato a capire che lui non è veramente capace di fare un mestiere del genere ci sono grandi generali
in italia o almeno così si pensa e dunque vittorio comanda soltanto pro forma ma in realtà l'esercito
sarà comandato dai grandi generali che abbiamo chi sono i grandi generali che abbiamo beh uno uno non è uno
scherzo è davvero un grande generale e garibaldi garibaldi lo tengono dentro senza altro ormai non
sono più i tempi in cui lo cacciavano via quando veniva a proporsi anzi per garibaldi si fanno le cose
in grande non è più questione di dire i volontari non li vogliamo perché politicamente sono pericolosi
no ormai si è capito basta mettere la faccia di garibaldi sui manifesti la gente viene a garibaldi
armano 40.000 volontari un intero esercito naturalmente c'è sempre un sottinteso però lui
fa la guerra da un'altra parte noi con l'esercito vero invadiamo e lui lo spediamo e l'altra volta
nel 59 l'abbiamo spedito a brescia a bergamo prima ancora a varese adesso siamo già lì dove lo
mandiamo lo mandiamo a trento mentre l'esercito marcia sul veneto garibaldi con i 40.000 volontari
marcerà su trento attraverso le montagne l'idea non è cattiva è peccato che garibaldi adesso che
gli danno un esercito comincia a non essere più il garibaldi di una volta a 59 anni che per l'epoca
non sono pochi neanche adesso sono così pochi devo dire per far la guerra in montagna a comandare
un esercito è molto logoro garibaldi quattro anni prima c'è stata la facendura della spromonte
ferito alla gamba imprigionato in fortezza fa fatica andare a cavallo cosa che per un generale
non è tanto semplice non è più quello di una volta comunque raccoglie i suoi volontari e si prepara
grossomodo dalle parti della valtellina a marciare verso nord est e sboccare nel trentino bene
e tolto dai piedi garibaldi rimangono i due generali che gli italiani credono siano grandi
generali la marmora e cialdini sono due grossi personaggi in italia la marmora è il più vecchio
importante generale piemontese a 62 anni ma non è solo un generale un uomo di potere da due anni è
presidente del consiglio a firenze capitale d'italia il presidente del consiglio la marmora
quando scoppia la guerra di si dimette dalla presidenza del consiglio per tornare a fare il
suo vero mestiere comandare l'esercito peccato che c'è anche un altro generale che ritiene di essere
come dire di avere tutte le carte per comandare l'esercito si chiama cialdini lui non è della
scuola piemontese un modenese un vecchio rivoluzionario è uno che negli ultimi anni si è fatto le ossa
facendo i lavori sporchi ha fatto l'assedio di gaeta catturando quindi il re di napoli ha fatto la
spromonte cercando di ammazzare garibaldi non c'è riuscito ma c'è andato vicino ha fatto la repressione
del brigantaggio cialdini e sulla cresta dell'onda forse dovrebbe comandarlo lui l'esercito
voi forse sapete e forse l'abbiamo detto nei giorni scorsi che non c'è niente di peggio quando
si deve gestire una guerra che non avere le idee chiare su chi comanda e su cosa si deve fare qui
bisognerebbe decidere e naturalmente la marmora e cialdini hanno due idee diverse su cosa si deve
fare la marmora vecchia scuola piemontese attraversiamo il mincio e andiamo avanti cialdini
che lui è emiliano vede anche la geografia da un altro punto di vista vede anche lo spazio da un
altro punto di vista perché pensare sempre come se avessimo la base a torino e si va avanti dritti
verso oriente immaginiamo che la nostra base a bologna e lavoriamo sul po ammassiamo l'esercito
sul po anziché sul mincio passiamo il po marciamo dritti su venezia da lì l'idea non ne sarebbe
cattiva neanche questa certo attraversare il po con l'esercito davanti al nemico non è uno scherzo
ma cialdini come dire garantisce che lui ce la farebbe a questo punto voi capite la patata bollente
e del re a chi diamo il comando e quale dei due piani mettiamo in esecuzione qui succede la cosa
disastrosa che succede quando non si hanno le idee chiare e cioè certo che è difficile scegliere i due
generali sono in gamba tutti e due come si fa a sceglierne uno solo diamo metà dell'esercito a uno e
metà all'altro i piani sono buoni tutti e due come si fa a scegliere e facciamole tutte e due le
cose tanto siamo grossi siamo forti e quindi la marmora con 12 divisioni entrerà dal mincio
cialdini con otto divisioni formalmente subordinato ma in realtà con un comando indipendente opererà sul
basso po e questo è già sempre come dire col senno di poi uno comincia a intravedere i motivi
per cui poi le guerre si perdono perché dividere un esercito che sarebbe più forte certo entrambe
le masse ognuna delle due la massa di la marmora sul mincio la massa di cialdini sul po più a est
più a sud ognuna delle due è più forte delle truppe austriache presenti l'ha detto l'austria ci hanno
75 mila uomini cialdini ne ha di più la marmora ne ha di più gli austriaci cosa devono fare stanno
aspettare di vedere che cosa succederà al comando dell'esercito austriaco c'è l'arciduca alberto
d'asburgo 46 anni è un buon generale a qualche difetto per esempio è mio peggio di me anche con gli
occhiali non ci vede però la carta geografica la sa usare e il servizio di spionaggio austriaco
funziona l'arciduca alberto viene a sapere abbastanza presto si sono divisi una massa sul
mincio una massa sul po noi siamo in mezzo cosa avrebbe fatto napoleone ne approfitti attacchi uno e
poi attacchi l'altro l'arciduca alberto si prepara il primo dei due italiani che si muove lui andrà ad
attaccarlo gli italiani all'inizio non si muovono veloci tanto per cambiare anche perché va detto non
è soltanto che non è facile passare i fiumi eccetera eccetera clausevice morto da una trentina
da anni allora aveva scritto che la guerra è la prosecuzione della politica con altri mezzi ed è
verissimo non si fa la guerra senza avere un obiettivo politico o almeno non si dovrebbe fare non si
dovrebbe fare la guerra senza sapere che cosa vuoi ottenere noi siamo alleati dei prussiani vogliamo
schiacciare l'austria benissimo e infatti i prussiani i quali stanno già pentendosi di essersi
alleati con gli italiani i prussiani continuano a insistere l'ambasciatore prussiano a firenze i
generali prussiani che vengono in visita andate avanti basta che andiate avanti fate qualcosa passate
il mincio dice ma ci sono le fortezze del quadrilatero peschiera mantova i prussiani consigliano lasciate
perdere le fortezze andate dentro andate all'isonzo marciate su vienna sentire queste cose la gente come
la marmora dice ma cosa vengono questi tedeschi a spiegarci cosa dobbiamo fare prima bisogna assediare
peschiera e poi si vede ma la marmora all'inizio non si muove veloce anche per un altro motivo ed è
che lui era presidente del consiglio fino al giorno prima e aveva anche l'interim del ministero degli
esteri quindi aveva in mano tutta la politica italiana e lui sa perché l'ha fatto lui questo
negoziato che c'è un mezzo accordo con napoleone terzo napoleone terzo il nostro ex alleato
non ha un po' paura della prussia napoleone terzo non vorrebbe che la prussia stravincesse
vincesse questa guerra napoleone terzo non vorrebbe che l'austria fosse annientata napoleone
terzo pensa se diamo un contentino agli italiani anche un grosso contentino a spese degli austriaci
che faranno i bravi e pagheranno l'austria non avrà la guerra in italia e potrà resistere alla
prussia quindi napoleone terzo ha fatto sapere alla marmora che lui sta discutendo con francesco
giuseppe d'austria e che se vanno un po' avanti in questo negoziato l'austria cede il veneto gratis
senza bisogno di fare la guerra capite che meraviglia la marmora si frega le mani forse questa guerra non
ci sarà bisogno di farla napoleone terzo ovviamente ha anche detto cercate di non far arrabbiare gli
austriaci però quindi voi andateci piano all'italia probabilmente conviene andarci piano questo è quello
che sa la marmora cialdini no a lui non l'hanno detto naturalmente ma la marmora si quindi non hanno
intenzione di fare granché prendono tempo nel frattempo preparano anche un altro pezzo di guerra
che è nuovo anche questo non c'era nel 59 non c'era nel 48 questo lo dobbiamo introdurre perché
avrà conseguenze fra poco c'è la flotta la guerra si fa anche nell'adriatico adesso c'è una grande
flotta italiana che è nata dalla fusione della marina sarda che non era male perché aveva la liguria
aveva genova aveva la spezia e la marina napoletana che era anche meglio era una buona marina da guerra
come sapete nel 60 la marina da guerra napoletana è passata interamente con armi e bagagli con i suoi
ammiragli in testa e con tutte le navi ai savoia ed è stata incorporata immediatamente e forma un grosso
nucleo della nuova marina italiana la marina italiana tanto per cambiare è molto più forte di
quella austriaca e quindi potrà spazzare via il nemico dall'adriatico il 21 giugno la flotta italiana
al comando dell'ammiraglio persano lascia la sua base di taranto e si inoltra nell'adriatico
due giorni dopo la marmora comincia a passare il mincio pianino non con tutti perché bisogna
lasciare delle truppe davanti a mantova e bisogna lasciare delle truppe davanti a peschiera
si va un po' a vedere cosa c'è al di là di questo benedetto mincio si guarda la cartina vede
che c'è un villaggio chiamato custozza ma insomma passa con una parte del suo esercito il giorno dopo
24 giugno anniversario di solferino l'arciduca alberto attacca la marmora se si fosse portato tutti
avrebbe 120 mila uomini se ne è portati solo 50 mila l'arciduca alberto ne ha 75 mila e se li
è portati tutti e dunque si combatte in tutta questa zona tra il mincio e l'adige come al solito
come nelle guerre precedenti nessuno di questi generali è molto in gamba neanche l'arciduca alberto
in realtà è così bravo nessuno sa gestire eserciti così grossi si va avanti un po' a caso si combattono
nazioni slegate separate intorno a custozza e in tanti altri villaggi in quel 24 giugno nel frattempo
fa un caldo da morire i soldati tanto per cambiare muoiono di sincope sotto il caldo con i loro cappotti
di lana che è la divisa standard dell'epoca non funziona niente non c'è da mangiare non c'è da bere gli
austriaci premono succede di tutto succede il caso eroico del quadrato di villa franca che verrà poi
celebrato per tanto tempo perché alla testa di uno dei battaglioni italiani che ci sono in quella
zona di villa franca c'è il principe ereditario il principe umberto e questo battaglione del principe
umberto viene attaccato dalla cavalleria nemica ed eroicamente resiste inquadrato vi dico questo
perché voi non lo sapete ma l'avete letta tutti una volta da bambini questa storia nel libro cuore nel
libro cuore c'è il papà di coretti che quando viene il re in visita a torino lo va a trovare e i
poliziotti non vogliono lasciarlo passare lui dice io ero nel quarto battaglione del 49esimo
reggimento a custozza e allora lo lasciò subito passare perché quello era il battaglione del principe
e nel libro cuore c'è questa descrizione meravigliosa che il papà di coretti fa di come la cavalleria
austriaca gli ulani che poi erano tutti polacchi hanno caricato questo battaglione a i demoni
scatenati ci vennero addosso come l'ira di dio ci vennero giravano tra i gruppi quadrati i cannoni
che parevano mulinati da un uragano sfondando ogni cosa dunque grande carica della cavalleria
austriaca a villa franca tutte le forze italiane presenti in zona si mettono in quadrato sapete che
la fanteria quando gli arrivava addosso la cavalleria se rimaneva schierata in linea veniva spazzata via
come un pagliaio quindi ci si ammucchiava in quadrato con le baionette in fuori l'eroica gesta
racconta come i battaglioni italiani a villa franca rimangono in quadrato tutto il giorno resistendo
alle cariche della cavalleria austriaca poi uno va a vedere l'arciduca alberto aveva in tutto un
reggimento di ulani 300 uomini due divisioni italiane 20.000 uomini rimangono in quadrato
tutto il giorno con i 300 ulani che gli galoppano intorno urlando in polacco e le due divisioni
resistono eroicamente la marmora manda messaggeri al comandante italiano generale della rocca il
quale quel giorno fa onore al suo soprannome era soprannominato macigno rimane lì immobile e quando
poi a cose finite la marmora gli dirà ma perché non sei venuto e la ma è la rocca in piemontese
risponderà ebrauchiel e michel avvio la cavalleria austriaca ecco 300 ulani hanno fermato due divisioni
dall'altra parte gli austrieci passano qualche reparto comincia a disorganizzarsi qualche reparto
comincia a scappare i soldati quando si mette male e soprattutto quando capiscono che i comandanti
non hanno le idee chiare in genere non hanno voglia di restare lì a farsi ammazzare di conseguenza
l'esercito italiano comincia a crollare non tutto ma una parte crolla scappano spiace dirlo ma il primo
che scappa è la marmora il quale vede dei reparti in fuga e dice ai suoi aiutanti che disfatta che
catastrofe nemmeno nel 49 dopodiché dice devo correre al ponte di goito per organizzare la
ritirata e ci crede e non sta scappando a tutti i difetti la marma non è che è un vigliacco
semplicemente si sta dicendo abbiamo perso si sono troppo abituati a perdere abbiamo perso quindi
l'importante è ritirarci in ordine quindi io corro a vedere che i ponti siano a posto e dunque la
battaglia di custozza è perduta la seconda battaglia di custozza così senza che nessuno ci abbia capito
niente però gli austrieci vengono avanti e i nostri scappano le perdite degli italiani non è una
battaglia di quelle in cui non muore nessuno gli italiani fra morti feriti e prigionieri perdono più
di 7.000 uomini anche gli austrieci ne perdono quasi 8.000 per noi vuol dire quasi il 15 per cento di
perdite non sono poche un esercito che ha perso il 15 per cento e in cui tutti i soldati sanno
abbiamo perso non lo riporti a combattere il giorno dopo così facilmente questa è una caratteristica
veramente delle battaglie di quei tempi dell'epoca di napoleone e dell'ottocento non hai bisogno di
distruggere un esercito per averlo battuto quando un esercito è rimasto lì un giorno e ha visto che viene
respinto e che le perdite sono alte l'esercito non combatterà più finché non lo hai fatto ritirare
riposare dunque bisogna ritirarsi ci ritiriamo dietro il mincio il giorno dopo 25 giugno la
marmora fa saltare i ponti sul mincio e si ritira dietro l'oglio ricordate che ci sono tutti questi
fiumi che scandiscono il teatro di queste guerre l'unico che non ha ancora capito il re vittorio
il quale per una volta l'idea giusta diceva beh oggi è andata così ma domani andiamo a dargli una
bunga raclé domani andiamo a dargli una bella botta la marmora dice maesta non avete capito
abbiamo perso e quindi ci ritiriamo e cialdini sul po col suo esercito che doveva passare il po e
prendere gli austriaci alle spalle queste sono ancora battaglie combattuta la vecchia maniera con
i battaglioni ammassati in linea in quadrato però ci sono anche le tecnologie moderne c'è il
telegrafo ormai si corrisponde in tempo reale già durante la battaglia quel 24 giugno il re aveva
mandato un primo telegramma a cialdini dicendogli di passare immediatamente il po perché noi siamo
impegnati qua con gli austriaci e non sappiamo come andrà e tu che sei là sotto passa il po li prenderai
alle spalle cialdini risponde passerò il po domani come previsto l'indomani il re è costretto
anzi no quella sera stessa scusate il re è costretto a mandare un altro telegramma cialdini abbiamo
perso perdite immense molti generali feriti dato ordine ripassare mincio però il re che il re dice
appena ci siamo riposati ripartiamo all'attacco lei cialdini intanto passi il po cialdini riceve
questo telegramma e non è più tanto sicuro di aver voglia di passare il po telegramma di cialdini
al re risultato battaglia oggi è grave e mi pone in grande perplessità poi già che c'è cialdini
cerca qualcuno che sia d'accordo con lui che in quella situazione non è il caso di andare avanti
telegramma di cialdini al ministro della guerra a firenze disastro accaduto sul mincio cambia molto
situazione passando domani po temo compromettere sorti italia dinastia vostra signoria che ne pensa
cialdini vorrebbe che il ministro della guerra gli dicesse no no ha ragione ha ragione non passi
il po io adesso non so più che sono le risposte del ministro della guerra fatto sta che cialdini
non si muove aspetta nuovi telegrammi la marmora bravo uomo il giorno dopo gli manda un altro
telegramma stia allerta stato armata deplorabile a questo punto cialdini si ritira cioè non solo
non passa il po ma decide di tornare indietro ripiega su bologna telegramma di cialdini dopo
disastro ieri sarebbe follia pensare passaggio po ciò comprometterebbe sorti paese dinastia di nuovo
dati ordini per concentrarmi verso bologna di conseguenza è bastata questa battaglia che nessuno
voleva inconcludente persa certo ma abbiamo sempre due eserciti ognuno dei quali è grande il doppio di
quello austriaco la marmora ormai è dietro l'olio cialdini ormai è a bologna cialdini che non ha visto
neanche un austriaco finora c'è di peggio la marmora si è giocato la faccia non si sente più
abbastanza autorevole da dare ordini a cialdini ergo quando cialdini avverte che lui si ritira su
bologna la marmora il 26 giugno gli manda un telegramma in cui gli dice più o meno
la marmora comandante in capo scrive a cialdini che formalmente è un suo subordinato la prego
caldamente di non abbandonare il po cialdini abbandona il po la marmora si dimette il re non
accetta le dimissioni la marmora dice ma fate comandante cialdini allora il re non accetta la
marmora rimane comandante cialdini però fa quello che vuole e intanto e intanto però la guerra non si
sta combattendo soltanto qui se si stesse combattendo soltanto qui ne vedevamo delle belle con tutto
l'esercito austriaco in italia invece l'esercito austriaco quello vero è in boemia e in boemia sono
entrati i prussiani e il 3 luglio si combatte in un posto chiamato sadova una battaglia decisiva
in cui i prussiani sbaragliano gli austriaci il 3 luglio a sadova gli austrici sono sbaragliati il
4 luglio francesco giuseppe manda un telegramma a napoleone terzo dicendogli se volete ci mettiamo
d'accordo per il veneto purché l'italia mi esca dalla guerra francesco giuseppe ci spera napoleone
terzo ci starebbe avvertono la marmora discutiamone noi forse forse a questo punto accetteremo anche
però siamo alleati con i prussiani e i prussiani hanno vinto a sadova ma la guerra non è finita i
prussiani vogliono stravincere i prussiani si aspettavano di stringere la mano alla marmora a
vienna poi vabbè hanno capito che la marmora non ci arriverà ma loro ci vogliono andare a vienna quindi
i prussiani ci diffidano fermamente dal fare una pace separata e noi tutto sommato visto che abbiamo
fatto questa figuraccia alla fine la pace separata non lo vogliamo fare vogliamo ancora riscattarci
potremmo riscattarci ci sono tante possibilità c'è garibaldi ve lo ricordate garibaldi è là
coi suoi 30 40 mila volontari che sta avanzando verso il trentino lentamente lui sta male in carrozza
e gli austriaci sono preparati gli austriaci hanno una paura maledetta di quello che potrebbe fare
garibaldi sulle montagne quindi hanno mandato truppe generali bravi garibaldi comincia a sostenere
qualche combattimento va un po avanti ma poco viene ferito un'altra volta come se non avesse
già abbastanza insomma è fermo cialdini cialdini dopo qualche giorno dice ma adesso forse potrei di
nuovo avvicinarmi al po però c'è questa posizione fortificata austriaca di borgoforte proprio lì sul
po prima bisogna assediarla e prenderla e poi passeremo cialdini mette l'assedio a borgoforte
nel frattempo scrive alla marmora suo superiore pregandolo caldamente di non muoversi dall'olio che
non vada a prendere altre batoste e rovinare tutto un'altra volta quello che pensa cialdini è che se la
marmora sta bravo sull'olio lui potrebbe fare grandi cose passando il po la marmora gli risponde
credo convenientissimo che lei passi subito il po finalmente cialdini passa il po l'undici luglio
entra a rovigo non sarebbe messo male però intanto si ferma a guardarsi intorno arci duca alberto è
sempre da qualche parte col suo esercito vittorioso chi lo sa dov'è se è a mantova se è a verona se è a
vicenza conviene andare cauti cialdini si ferma si fermano tutti anche perché adesso si sono
ricordati voi no ma loro sì c'è la flotta e dalla flotta potremmo ricavare quelle soddisfazioni che
finora ci sono mancate la flotta è arrivata ad ancona il 25 giugno al comando dell'ammiraglio
persano è molto più forte della flotta austriaca e ha ordini precisi sbarazzare l'adriatico dalle navi
da guerra nemiche il 25 la flotta di persano è arrivata ad ancona due giorni dopo il 27 la flotta
austriaca al comando dell'ammiraglio tegettov esce in mare e viene davanti ad ancona come a dire
venite fuori se avete coraggio persano non esce gli austriaci vanno avanti e indietro finché vogliono
davanti ad ancona e poi se ne tornano a casa il governo dovrebbe preoccuparsi ma in realtà il
governo ha una tale paura di perdere queste costosissime navi nuove tutte nuove che sono
costate sacrifici sangue sudore e lacrime ai contribuenti italiani c'è la tasso sul macinato
per pagare queste corazzate che il governo in fondo dà ragione a persano è meglio non correre
rischi voi sentite quali ordini riceve persano dal ministro della marina de pretis e ditemi cosa può
fare un ammiraglio che ha degli ordini del genere il ministro invita l'ammiraglio a mantenere una vigile
minacciosa difensiva però però intanto cosa sta succedendo che tra un po' i prussiani arrivano a vienna
e tra un po' la guerra è finita davvero e noi rimaniamo con un pugno di mosca in mano bisogna fare
qualcosa il 14 luglio si tiene a ferrara un consiglio di guerra in cui in pratica si decide
la destituzione di la marmora su 20 divisioni cialdini ne prenderà 14 quindi diventa lui il
più importante e all'ordine di marciare sul lisonzo dal lisonzo voi lo sapete si va a lubiana a trieste
a vienna come si vuole cialdini marcerà sul lisonzo quanto all'ammiraglio persia persano riceve
stavolta ordini precisi dovrà attaccare entro otto giorni se no sarà destituito questo il 14 luglio
persano aspetta sei giorni sperando che arrivi il controordine poi finalmente il 20 luglio esce da
ancona e si spinge con la flotta in mezzo alle isole croate vicino a un'isoletta che si chiama
lissa c'è la flotta austriaca dell'ammiraglio tegetov che lo aspetta ora intorno a questa
battaglia di lissa ci sono tante cose che si sanno altre credenze leggende e altre cose che
magari non si sanno una credenza una leggenda molto amata e che sia stata l'ultima battaglia
navale fra genovesi e veneziani perché ovviamente la squadra italiana è fatta di genovesi e di
napoletani la squadra austriaca si dice loro hanno ancora il veneto hanno ancora venezia e
ancora la flotta di san marco sulle navi austriache si parla veneto in parte non è neanche del tutto
falso ci può scappare l'ordine in veneto sulle navi austriache va però detto che io ho visto
l'elenco delle perdite austriache alla battaglia di lissa i marinai sono quasi tutti croati e fra
l'altro ho anche trovato preparando questa lezione sui giornali italiani dell'epoca prima della
battaglia di lissa uscivano articoli razzisti del tipo perché dovremmo aver paura della flotta
austriaca è tutta fatta da marinai croati si sa che i croati ai croati l'acqua non piace basta vedere
che non si lavano mai questo è il tono dei discorsi fatti in italia lo scoppio della guerra fatto sta
che l'altra cosa qui invece non si riflette tanto è che razza di navi da guerra sono queste cosa sono
le navi da guerra del 1866 se andate a cercarle su internet le corazzate che abbiamo perso in quella
battaglia re d'italia palestra ecco sono navi stranissime perché c'è un'evoluzione velocissima
delle tecnologie le marine da guerra hanno appena digerito questa grossa novità del vapore e quindi
sono navi a vapore ci sono ancora molti velieri ma sono tutti d'accordo che i velieri ormai sono
secondari quello che conta è la nave a vapore però queste navi a vapore se voi le guardate hanno un
grande fumaiolo in mezzo e poi tre alberi per le vele perché non sono ben sicuri che poi il vapore
non si guasti e che le vele non tornino utili hanno appena cominciato a digerire il vapore che arriva
quest'altra novità la corazzata quattro anni prima in una baia della virginia durante la guerra civile
americana per la prima volta sudisti e nordisti hanno messo in mare degli esperimenti delle navi
di legno ma tutte coperte da piastre d'acciaio corazzate e di colpo tutte le flotte esistenti al mondo
sono diventate obsolete perché si è visto che una corazzata affonda tutti i velieri di legno che
vuole senza farsi male quindi tutte le vecchie navi non contano più niente tutti hanno costruito
corazzate a vapore e a vela senza sapere cosa sono e senza sapere come si usano perché sono navi nuove
nessuno le ha mai guidate in battaglia questo va tenuto presente la battaglia di lista è una battaglia
tanto per cambiare confusa in cui nessuno sa bene come gestire queste macchine poderose che hanno
nessuno sa bene come gestirle però alla fine si scopre che gli austriaci sanno gestirle un pochino
meglio persano da degli ordini i suoi comandanti di squadra genovesi e napoletani non li eseguono e
gli austriaci vengono sotto si comincia a sparare gli austriaci sparano meglio persano ha abbandonato
la corazzata che era la sua ammiraglia per spostarsi su un'altra nave ecco l'identicavo
questa cosa hanno capito talmente poco come sarà la guerra navale del futuro che c'è l'idea che in
futuro il modo migliore per affondare le navi nemiche sarà di speronarle e hanno costruito
addirittura delle navi che chiamano arieti il più bello si chiama l'affondatore che è costruito
apposta per investire sulla fiancata le navi nemiche bucarle e affondarle persano sposta il
suo comando su questa nave meravigliosa peccato che non avverte i suoi comandanti che quindi non
sanno più dove trovarlo dopodiché il combattimento va avanti gli austriaci sparano meglio semplicemente
gli austriaci subiscono grossi danni grosse perdite ma due corazzate italiane saltano in aria e
affondano con i loro capitani e con quasi tutto l'equipaggio alla fine noi abbiamo perso due
corazzate più di 600 morti 160 feriti gli austriaci hanno avuto 38 morti 138 feriti non hanno perso
nessuna nave ognuno torna in porto anzi tegetto avendo vinto se ne torna a casa persano rimane in
mare per un po poi manda un telegramma abbiamo combattuto una grande battaglia e siamo rimasti
padroni delle acque in italia si fanno grandi festeggiamenti suonano le campane e escono i
titoloni sui giornali poi quando persano torna in porto ad ancona gli chiedono dove sono le corazzate
re d'italia e palestro e tocca ammettere che le corazzate sono affondate e gli austriaci quanto ne
hanno perse nessuna a questo punto succedono un certo numero di cose uno persano viene destituito
e mandato sotto processo e sarà fortunato che non lo fucilano due abbiamo fatto un'altra figuraccia
e i prussiani ci stanno dicendo va bene abbiamo lasciato giocare ancora un po ma adesso basta noi
abbiamo finito e quindi adesso fine ci sarebbe un'ultima speranza garibaldi il quale in realtà
si sta muovendo è quasi arrivato a trento garibaldi a tanti uomini davanti a lui gli austriaci sono pochi
sono bravi sono generali bravi il kun garibaldi si infogna nel trentino il kun a un certo punto lo
attacca lo prende di sorpresa prendere di sorpresa garibaldi una volta non ci riusciva nessuno adesso non è
più lo stesso uomo il kun cattura un migliaio di garibaldini poi garibaldi arriva cerca di
metterci una pezza siccome comunque il talento c'è ancora alla fine riesce a evitare il disastro e kun
si ritira con i suoi mille prigionieri questa è la vittoria di bezzecca che viene celebrata da un
paese che aveva un tale bisogno di vittorie che a questo punto la battaglia di bezzecca viene presentata
come una vittoria e però insomma garibaldi ha perso millequattrocento uomini gli austriaci hanno
persi cento il giorno dopo 23 luglio l'italia cede alle fortissime pressioni della prussia e accetta una
tregua la guerra sarebbe finita e però forse forse chi lo sa potrebbe ancora darsi che magari
riusciamo ancora a rimetterci su aspettiamo a firmare il trattato di pace sotto banco mandano
a dire a garibaldi ma tu muoviti perché magari ci arrivi a trento se arrivi a trento prima che abbiamo
firmato il trattato di pace i prussiani si infuriano firmate basta è finita gli austriaci
sono quasi contenti perché se firmano con i prussiani e noi siamo ancora in guerra tutto sommato
alla fine lo capiscono anche gli italiani il 9 agosto quando garibaldi è quasi a trento gli
arriva il famoso telegramma la guerra è finita torna indietro di trento ne riparleremo poi un'altra
volta garibaldi come sapete tutti risponde con un telegramma di una sola parola obbedisco e la
guerra è finita ed è quasi finito il risorgimento ed è anche quasi finita questa nostra lezione di
stasera ma quasi perché in realtà io voglio ancora dirvi qualche cosa e capirete poi perché la guerra è
finita dunque abbiamo il veneto perché alla fine nel trattato di pace la prussia ha la gentilezza
di obbligare gli austriaci a cedere il veneto mancano trento e trieste ma di quello si riparlerà fra
tanto tempo manca roma e di quella si vorrebbe riparlarne di roma però capite c'è un grosso problema
se fosse soltanto il papa papa ha qualche mercenario ma insomma non è certo lui che ci ferma il motivo per
cui non siamo ancora andati a roma finora è che il nostro vecchio amico e alleato napoleone terzo
negli ultimi anni in francia ha deciso che il sostegno del partito cattolico per lui è indispensabile
e quindi la francia grande paese cattolico sostiene il papa a roma ci sono i francesi
una guerra contro il papa è impensabile vorrebbe dire che napoleone terzo ci dichiara guerra e voi
capite come andrebbe a finire ci si può provare per vie traverse come al solito dov'è garibaldi
garibaldi obbedisce è tornato garibaldi ti lasciamo mano libera se vuoi provare a prendere roma tu con i tuoi
il governo non c'entra garibaldi ci prova garibaldi ci crede sempre fino all'ultimo nel 67 mette in piedi un esercito
marcia su roma ma purtroppo non è più l'uomo di una volta lo sapete vincono i francesi battaglia di mentana
e allora roma neanche a parlarne finché c'è napoleone terzo
fortuna vuole nostra che a un certo punto napoleone terzo fa lo sbaglio della sua vita
la guerra alla prussia la prussia avete capito è lì che fa i suoi calcoli ne facciamo fuori uno per volta
noi siamo molto forti e molto bravi a fare la guerra ma quegli altri non l'hanno ancora capito
i francesi credono ancora di essere loro il migliore esercito del mondo
la prussia ha fatto fuori l'austria è diventata il leader indiscusso dei paesi tedeschi
la baviera la sassonia tutti quei piccoli regni simpatici nel 66 erano alleati dell'austria
ma adesso sono stati costretti a allearsi con la prussia nel 70 la prussia è pronta per sconfiggere
anche la francia e impadronirsi dell'alsazia e lorena e creare un grande impero tedesco basta
solo un incidente lo provocano napoleone terzo ci casca dichiara guerra alla prussia finisce
malissimo come sapete napoleone terzo viene battuto a sedan il suo esercito accerchiato
napoleone terzo è costretto a rendersi al nemico abdica finisce l'impero repubblica francese comune
di parigi mille cose che qui non ci interessano a noi interessa una cosa sola è caduto napoleone
terzo tutti si fregano le mani e lui che 11 anni prima ci aveva dato la lombardia naturalmente ma
adesso era molto ingombrante tutti si fregano le mani in italia tranne uno devo dire l'unico
che pensa in modo diverso dagli altri e garibaldi garibaldi che a mentana tre anni prima nel 67 è
stato battuto dai francesi è quasi ammazzato dai francesi però garibaldi quando sente dire che
napoleone terzo se n'è andato e adesso la francia è una repubblica gli tornano i vecchi bollori
repubblicani a garibaldi le repubbliche piacciono e i prussiani con l'elmo chiodato non gli piacciono
invece di conseguenza garibaldi è l'unico italiano che invece di essere entusiasta che i prussiani hanno
sbaragliato i francesi decide di partire e mettersi al servizio dei francesi garibaldi vecchio malconcio
in carrozza dolorante da tutte le parti si presenta in francia i francesi sono così disperati
che gli danno un comando pur protestando gliene dicono di tutti i colori il parlamento francese ma lui comunque
si fa anche eleggere deputato al parlamento francese già che c'è ma comunque comanda ancora in guerra per la
repubblica francese riesce ancora a vincere una piccola battaglia contro i prussiani è l'unico generale
francese che prende in battaglia una bandiera prussiana immaginatevi come sono contenti i francesi
che è un italiano è l'unico che ecco ma quello è garibaldi in italia il discorso è un altro la
francia è a terra il papa è rimasto solo andiamo a roma grazie a sedan noi facciamo il 20 settembre la
breccia di portapia il fatto che l'italia unita si è fatta in questo modo che abbiamo raccontato in
questi giorni peserà sulla coscienza del paese e anche sull'immagine internazionale del paese
qualche anno dopo il principe bismarck che era uno piuttosto brutale dirà a vittorio emanuele terzo
allora ancora principe ereditario voi italiani siete il popolo delle tre s solferino nel 59 avete
preso la lombardia sadova nel 66 avete preso il veneto sedan nel 70 avete preso roma nessuna delle
tre s l'avete fatta voi ecco questa è un po l'immagine dell'italia unita naturalmente nel mondo
dopo di che io ho voluto arrivare fin qua e anziché congedarci per portarci fino al 20 settembre e alla
breccia di portapia perché stasera c'è un piccolo fuori programma che non sapeva nessuno siccome sulla
breccia di portapia quindi lo stato italiano che dichiara guerra al papa si potrebbero avere tante
opinioni naturalmente può essere interessante sentirne almeno una io pensavo che vi possa far
piacere sentire l'opinione del professore di freddi che è qui con noi e che viene a concludere con me
buonasera scusate per questa invasione di campo ma adesso che ho preso il microfono non lo cedo
facilmente ma che vuole che opinione possiamo avere di quello che è successo il 20 settembre 1870
che come la prima guerra dell'iraq voi vi ricordate quando gli stati uniti una ventina di anni fa credo
forse il 90 91 fecero la guerra all'iraq e fecero un errore madornale perché avrebbero potuto arrivare
fino alla fine per l'appunto prendere bagdad sarebbe finita lì sarebbe caduto saddam hussein e invece non
lo fecero e ci vuole una seconda guerra dell'iraq che fu fatta poi nel 2003 per arrivare fino a bagdad
e in italia purtroppo abbiamo fatto solo la prima cioè i bersaglieri come sapete non sono entrati a
portapia hanno sfondato le mura hanno preso roma roma è diventata capitale prima abbiamo sentito la
marmora era firenze che è stata capitale per qualche anno e poi invece roma è diventata la capitale d'italia
ma il risorgimento non è finito perché è la guerra non è stata conclusa non sono andati oltre tevere e
la rimane ancora una piccola zona d'italia che deve essere liberata naturalmente che si chiama lo stato
del vaticano e la cosa naturalmente non tutti applaudono ma la cosa interessante è che dal 1870
fino al 1929 perlomeno l'italia sentiremo se barbero su questo è d'accordo l'italia è stata uno stato laico
perché la chiesa ovviamente non era stata sconfitta completamente il papa era lì non era tornato a
gerusalemme da dove era partito naturalmente dove avrebbe dovuto andare alla fine di tutta la storia
ma i governi che poi si successero in seguito fino all'arrivo di mussolini in realtà erano
governi fatti da cattolici perché tutti i presidenti del consiglio credo che formalmente
perlomeno fossero cattolici ma erano anche massoni ovviamente avevano un atteggiamento molto diverso
e furono governi come quelli che nella seconda parte dell'ottocento dopo il 1870 prima del 1900
fecero cose meravigliose vi racconto solo un episodio se posso di quella storia lì ci fu un momento il papa
il papa era leone tredicesimo un momento in cui il governo italiano decise di chiudere i conti con altre
storie che erano successe molto prima e decisero di ereggere o erigere una statua a giordano bruno a
roma dove a campo dei fiori dove era stato bruciato come ricordate 17 febbraio del 1600 e dove naturalmente
non si era potuto festeggiare o meglio perlomeno ricordare questo avvenimento perché c'è stato
il papa appunto fino al 1870 leone tredicesimo dice ma questo sarebbe un insulto talmente grande
che se voi lo fate io me ne vado in esilio no ma è meraviglioso non aspettiamo altro che questo
succeda ci sono le lettere che poi tu potresti andare a trovare eccetera leone tredicesimo che scrive
che scrive all'imperatore d'ausria e dice maestà io insomma questa cosa non l'accetto se lei mi
permette io verrei in esilio da lei e sembra che l'imperatore gli abbia detto naturalmente se lei
vuole andare in esilio vada pure ma non da bene naturalmente se ne va da qualche altra parte
quindi leone tredicesimo rimane si deve mangiare naturalmente la bile il fegato e deve accettare
questa statua questa statua rimane lì ma le cose cambiano ovviamente il risorgimento
cade nel 1922 diciamo così arriva il fascismo e come voi sapete nel 1929
mussolini firma il concordato con la santa sede leone tredicesimo è morto tra l'altro
il papa più vecchio che è durato fino a 92 anni
ratzinger nel 90 il prossimo anno quindi forse batterà questo questo record ma non
è più regnante il papa più lungo appunto più longevo e più undicesimo dice allora
stavolta chiudo io la storia e chiede a mussolini pensate voi di dire che durante
all'atto della firma del concordato la statua di giordano bruno venga abbattuta come simbolo
simbolo per l'appunto di del fatto che è finita no questa parentesi nella storia del vaticano
e mussolini che come voi sapete era un ateo era partito come altro era anche socialista
era uno che da giovane andava a fare i dibattiti sull'ateismo per difendere l'ateismo
e aveva un argomento che è simile a quello che che ha sandro barbero tutte le sere metteva
un orologio sul tavolo e diceva ti do alzando gli occhi al cielo naturalmente no ti do cinque
minuti per fulminarmi se ci sei aspettava cinque minuti purtroppo se c'era quello non
l'ha fatto no e quindi alla fine no mussolini è diventato adulto è diventato poi appunto
dittatore ma si è ricordato nel 29 che forse poteva fermare questa cosa e disse la statua
del triste frate rimane dov'è e questa è la fine di questa storia ovviamente no e
purtroppo il risorgimento sa da fare ancora quindi io personalmente credo che aspettiamo
la quarta guerra di indipendenza anche se forse qualcuno dice la quarta guerra di indipendenza
è stata la prima guerra mondiale no perché ha liberato l'ultima parte d'italia che rimane
ma molti si dimenticano appunto che ce n'è ancora una piccola enclave e a volte sembra leggendo
i giornali che quello sia il vero presidente il papare diciamo così no perché ancora c'è
questo atteggiamento nei confronti del vaticano quindi effettivamente il risorgimento c'è
stato ma mi sembra che sia inconcluso posso ancora fare una piccola parentesi visto che
ho il sono le 11 20 no perché volevo dire visto che siamo qui in due sul sul palcoscenico
uno storico e un matematico uno potrebbe dire va è una strana coppia che non c'entra niente
però abbiamo sentito una storia meravigliosa in queste tre serate io ne ho sentite solo due
perché la prima non sono arrivato in tempo una storia meravigliosa però che mi ha fatto
venire in mente ieri soprattutto quando hai citato il modo in cui gli italiani diciamo
così si sono difesi dall'attacco degli austriaci allagando le la pianura di vercelli le risaie
di vercelli ed è la storia che narra tolstoi nella in guerra e pace tu sai dove vuoi arrivare
no già ride naturalmente che narra è una storia che tra l'altro ha moltissimi punti
in comune con quella che abbiamo sentito anche perché le guerre all'epoca si facevano effettivamente
così una storia che brevissimamente una storia che come dice tolstoi è come un pendolo
ed è questa la parte che mi interessa di tolstoi appunto il fatto che lui usi metafore matematiche
per illustrare gli avvenimenti storici anche se il modo corretto di fare è usare metafore storiche
per illustrare concetti matematici e naturalmente e la metafora che usa tolstoi è quella del pendolo
se tutto usa una metafora che è balistico meccanica dice gli eserciti sono come due masse
che hanno o reagiscono secondo il principio di azione reazione quindi quando due eserciti
si incontrano si fanno esattamente come due corpi nella meccanica che si respingono con forza
che sono proporzionali ovviamente alla forza che avevano quando si sono incontrate ma c'è questo pendolo
un pendolo che tolstoi ci dice si alza nel 1789 il pendolo viene alzato dalla rivoluzione francese
rimane sospeso per un certo periodo è un pendolo con una grande forza una grande massa
e ad un certo punto ci vuole qualcuno che lo lascia andare e che lasci fare quello che il pendolo deve fare
questo qualcuno è lo zio di napoleone terzo quello che abbiamo evocato che alessandro ha evocato più volte fino a questa sera
non è napoleone terzo ma è napoleone primo ed è lui che lascia andare questo pendolo e questo pendolo dove va
beh va dalla francia verso la russia questa volta e questo pendolo ci metterà parecchi anni perché ci saranno due guerre
nel 1805 poi nel 1812 napoleone arriverà fino a mosca e come ci arriverà esattamente nel modo in cui i piemontesi si sono difesi dall'invasione austriaca
nella seconda guerra di indipendenza cioè facendo terra bruciata delle terre lasciando che napoleone penetrasse dentro la russia
arrivando a mosca napoleone trova la città deserta i moscoviti se ne sono scappati l'esercito non ha combattuto si è semplicemente ritirato
c'è qualcuno che l'analogo di giulai solo che dall'altra parte questa volta fa la parte del buono ed è il famoso maresciallo
il fel maresciallo perché poi l'esercito russo a quell'epoca era in larga parte tedesco anche come generali tra l'altro e come formazione
ed è il maresciallo cutuzzo se voi andate oggi a san pietroburgo ad esempio di fronte a nostra signora di casan che è una chiesa fatta come san pietro
che è stata copiata addirittura con la colonnata del bernini trovate la statua ancora oggi 200 anni dopo del maresciallo cutuzzo
oppure se andate a vedere l'ermitage il palazzo d'inverno degli zar che quello trovate c'è un lunghissimo corridoio con tutti i generali che hanno combattuto le guerre napoleoniche
e agli inizi c'è questo enorme ritratto del maresciallo ma questo è il pendolo e qual è la legge del pendolo che nel momento in cui arriva alla sua massima parte dall'altra parte dove era partito ritorna indietro
naturalmente napoleone non sa che cosa fare in una mosca deserta a un certo punto arriva l'inverno l'esercito francese incomincia a indietreggiare verso il confine e questa volta si muovono i russi
che inseguono l'esercito francese e incominciano a dargli battaglia e qui noi abbiamo questa sera sentito ci siamo anche divertiti a sentire come sono questi italiani
questo coraggio che in fin dei conti chi non ce l'ha non se lo può dare beh sapete che cosa fa Napoleone? Napoleone scappa, lascia l'esercito francese che era entrato in Russia con 500.000 uomini
e questo esercito quando uscirà ne avrà 30.000 ancora ma Napoleone non ci sarà più perché è scappato prima con la sua bella guardia e è fuggito abbandonando l'esercito
e questo pendolo che cosa fa? Beh alla fine ritorna esattamente dall'altra parte e ci sarà poi lo zar, lo zar Alessandro di Russia che entra invece poi dopo il 1812 a Parigi
questo perché lo dico? Perché Tolstoi ha quest'idea straordinaria che la matematica può servire a raccontare la storia in parte attraverso queste metafore appunto che avevo detto
la meccanica, i pendoli eccetera ma in parte in una cosa che Alessandro quando gliel'ho ricordata ieri è messa a ridere naturalmente ma che invece a me fa commozione quasi
l'ultima parte di Guerra e Pace e le ultime 150-200 pagine sono un racconto che non ha più a che vedere con la guerra, la guerra è finita, gli amori sono finiti
e un trattato ed è un trattato di teoria della storia. Che cos'è la storia secondo Tolstoi? E' certamente quella che raccontano gli storici e la storia dei grandi personaggi
nel caso di Tolstoi c'era lo zar Alessandro che non è apparso nemmeno attraverso i suoi successori nelle guerre di indipendenza
ma c'era naturalmente l'imperatore dei francesi Napoleone I che in questo caso era poi diventato Napoleone III
c'era l'imperatore austriaco con cui lo zar si incontra per allearsi contro Napoleone che non era quello che c'era in seguito Francesco Giuseppe
bensì Francesco II poi I e così via. E allora qual è la metafora che dice Tolstoi? Tutti questi personaggi sono ovviamente quelli che attraggono la nostra attenzione
perché sono meravigliosi e si possono raccontare su di loro tantissime storie
ma attenzione lui dice perché questo può anche essere una specie di illusione ottica
di farci credere che la storia è fatta da personaggi di questo genere
però se Napoleone I o Napoleone III decidi andiamo a combattere e nessuno si muove
e ci va lui a combattere, uno, una persona. Forse le guerre sarebbero belle fatte solo da questi condottieri
in realtà come abbiamo detto migliaia, addirittura centinaia di migliaia di soldati si muovono
e le guerre sono combattute da tutti questi soldati
di cui ovviamente non si può raccontare la storia individuale perché sono troppi
e Tolstoi dice ciascuno di essi dà un contributo che lui chiama infinitesimo
che non è affatto infinitesimo, è molto piccolo, è finito ma piccolo
e allora dice Tolstoi la storia non è appunto il contributo dei grandi condottieri
ma è la somma di tutti questi piccoli contributi infinitesimi
e dice come si fa a calcolare una somma di infinitesimi?
Tolstoi che era uno che aveva studiato tante cose, l'aveva anche insegnata ai contadini della sua tenuta
a Jasna e a Poliana conosceva la matematica e dice c'è un'operazione matematica
che ci dice come fare somme di infinitesimi ed è quella che coloro tra voi che hanno fatto
scuole superiori o l'università, il tipo scientifico conosce bene, si chiama l'operazione di integrazione
Tolstoi dice la storia è l'integrale dei contributi infinitesimi di tutte le persone
che hanno contribuito a combattere le guerre ma anche più in generale a fare la storia
ed era questa metafora matematica che fa vedere come in fondo possono stare sullo stesso palco
anche uno storico matematico che fanno cose diverse ma che tutto sommato si possono intendere
anche se io adesso è meglio che me ne vada e te lascio a te
in realtà facevo meglio scendere anch'io con Pier Giorgio Odifreddi, non sono sceso
quindi vi dico ancora semplicemente che avete avuto ancora il privilegio di sentire Odifreddi
di parlare di storia l'anno prossimo verrò io a parlarvi di algebra ovviamente, per quest'anno è finita